we're looking at some exciting ways to  tell more of the American story on our  currency so I said in over the summer  that we were going to continue to honor  Alexander Hamilton so I wasn't surprised  I've always been a big fan of Alexander  have you seen Hamilton I hip up and you  loved it it's an extraordinary open play  and look he left an incomparable legacy  in terms of our financial and political  system so he deserves the attention and  credit he's getting so people you know  should never have been worried that we  were going to do anything that would be  to erase that memory but we're going to  do some things that are interesting and  pretty soon we'll have something to  announce